thrilled to have back here in person
great to see this man in the flesh
clifford the big red dog is available
now in theaters and on paramount plus
david alan greer how are you sir rich
you know it's so great to be back in the
studio thank you
i like being here in person you know
last time i think we spoke via
phone indeed something on the phone
pandemic conversation yeah it's never as
good as being in the studio well we
missed you uh and it's okay if you want
to admit did your coffee mug break and
you wanted to know you wanted a new one
and no you don't know me at all i have
to have backups
[Laughter]
it's not about breaking no it's like
there's a ceramic depth chart oh yeah
yeah yeah i guess so i'm gonna now i'm
gonna be too deep you'll be too deep
just in case
something happens that's the way you
like to play defense the two the two
deep mugs you know plan b
all right and b always plan b i
appreciate that
and i i feel
yes that my mug love was
uh questioned oh boy by certain
listeners viewers okay but i was
speaking from the heart man right okay
we don't have to we don't have to
revisit it
but um yes it's still one of my top top
mugs okay fantastic yes well i'm
thrilled that you are here uh greatly
appreciated
so does my entire family
i don't know if you're aware uh if you
if you've read your reviews for clifford
the big red dog oh that is available now
in theaters and on paramount plus but my
eight-year-old daughter yes called it
the greatest movie she's seen in her
life
that ladies and gentlemen she may be the
first
female president of this it's like
what is her name she's got this stuff
taylor
maddingly eisen her middle name is
mattingly after my favorite baseball
player don mattingly yes mattingly
eisner president maddington
exactly clifford the big red dog in
theaters now taylor said because we want
saturday night there was a certain
um you know uh we had a dinner party at
our house outdoors
and to make sure that my my daughter was
occupied oh thankfully uh paramount plus
came in and was a very terrific way and
she couldn't wait to see it she's a big
uh fan of the book series and dogs in
general
and now david alan greer thank you you
know so is my daughter but she's 13 and
a half so she was not interested in
clifford that's for children she is a
teenager okay and she reminds me every
day okay own music different than mine
clothing sense of style all of it so
clifford the tick tock dog would be more
oh tick tock is what is that like
clifford yeah she's not on she's not on
social media but so whenever she's with
me she's like man look at tick tock i'm
like why why
what is there to look at i'm an old man
now what is this tick tock see my issue
is is um my my oldest he's 13 which is
why i went straight for the tick tock
because he's totally nuts about that um
he also wants to watch youtube and that
is a particularly dangerous wormhole for
thirteen years to go on but at least
it's full full length tick tock is like
how to fly to the moon in 30 seconds
right or you should need to rock it now
space boom and you're on the moon you're
an astronaut that's what i mean there's
more to it than that there is definitely
more to it than that you know yeah they
do cut to the chase a little bit quicker
at least youtube they get you in there
and they really indoctrinate you
you don't need vitamins you just need
dirt that's all you need just rub it on
there right eat it i know it's it'll
cure everything
so i say to him get off of tick tock and
he goes why doesn't the rich eisen show
and get off of utah because why there's
a rich eisenhower youtube page and it's
just like okay now you guys if you were
on tick tock think how short your day
would be well rich eisner sports david
greer he's gone now sure's always over
that'll be it and that'll wrap it up
that'd be it well tj jefferson is our
social media grand maester in the corner
and he just you know uh he you you
you're you're how old are you tj i'm old
man okay see there's no but he's he's
he's much younger than me i know
although wait a minute do we have this
photograph let's put it up on the screen
uh if you don't mind uh mike hoskins um
did tj you and tj have met before we
hung out man back in the day day so
there's a back in the day day photograph
of you tj and ashton kutcher there it is
right there look at that look how young
i am i have hey man that was like 2001.
i still have the hat where is this is
this like a pizza place what is this i'm
going to tell you where this was at
don't tell me
this was at an airport
okay and this is a little place we went
in to grab some food because we were on
our way to costa rica exactly boom
costa rica did you guys vacation you
guys vacation together in costa rica
as i recall yes it was an opening of an
online casino yes
in san jose yep we were we were flown
down there
and it was a very intense was it 24
hours it was like 48 for some
but it was i mean you got down i know i
was jet lagged completely mm-hmm i was
so jet-lagged and i fell down these
stone steps like slipped because they
were all stone and and it was like kind
of raining
and i was like oh my god under normal
circumstances i would have got in bed
but i just piled on the advil and
midnight's guy partying
yeah was that your recollection too
i just remember it was you know a lot of
people flew down friday my crew kind of
flew down
and we ran out met up with dagon airport
was like either friday night or saturday
morning so everyone there had a full
night partying before we got there and
from what i understand
it was uh it was quite the spec we got
it in i remember they said there was
like one complimentary thing you could
go like um
what do you call it when you on the on
the wire thing and then zip lining zip
line zip lining
what the hell you could go
climbing or you had to pick one so i
chose the zip line okay and i made it
you know i made it through but it was
zip lining in the jungle well you
started you they took you all the way up
in the very top and we went first and i
was like cool that was fun they were
like nah man you got five more cause you
gotta go all the way down
all the way down yeah like you would go
and then you would stop
you know on a little pad or something
and yeah it was fun it was a good trip
dave and alan greer here on the rich
eisen show here in person clifford the
big big red dog available now in
theaters and on paramount plus joe
pickett is a new drama series that's uh
exclusively on spectrum starting next
month we'll hit on that in a second and
that photograph i see you had a red
wings lit on from well you know i'm from
detroit i do know that sir first of all
people are watching you're a michigan
man yes come on you know how we do i do
know that first of all
uh folks don't know
we were sharing the love for michigan
football man for michigan
to lose to michigan state was so
horrifying it was
the only thing that made it right is
when the rankings came out two weeks
later
we were
i don't know how that happened i'll tell
you how it happened how does it happen
okay michigan state got so up to play
michigan because people unless you're in
michigan or you're an alumni you don't
understand there's only two games in the
whole season michigan state ohio state
correct ohio state is
is everything yes
right under that is michigan state our
arch rivals
it was a really good game i i mean
halfway through i thought we got this i
was tweeting snarky stuff
they snuck us but it was a it's what i
heard a guy on radio say it was the best
loss michigan could ever have had why is
that because the next week when michigan
state was routed by purdue yes a much
lower ranked team
that meant more than our almost win yet
we still lost lost to michigan that
michigan state that's why we were ranked
one slot higher and of course only
someone with a michigan degree not a
michigan state degree could figure that
out clearly all right we understand that
okay so but but why are you tweeting out
during the game david allen
what i do
that's what i do
way premature too you should know better
nah pretty mature like if i were a boxer
it would be round one
knockout baby two seconds later i just
saw no it just i should have
he was a good fighter you know
[Laughter]
i know that's what you're i have to it
was too much because i like to jameel
jamil hill mm-hmm i like to uh nag and
well she's got she smoked cigars in her
michigan state jerseys after beating
michigan yeah like she's
she is the one that i would want to she
started well she she always does when it
comes to state you know but but
kind of
bringing it all full circle of what
you're saying yes is that michigan
is michigan state's super bowl
and ohio state
is michigan's super bowl the problem is
for michigan
you know is that super bowl has been um
you know lost a lot lately well i don't
expect them to win this year so let's
just be honest so are you going to tweet
out during that game too well yeah
because i know what that's going to be
i know what that's going to be so i
could either go one or two ways how are
you going to do this tweet my real
feeling which is depression i'm it's
over it's over it's over it's over or
just blind euphoria which is i can't
even just what we want to do we don't
want to win see we want to prime you
guys up but next year
we knock you out you know
that's harder that's harder to maintain
it is because it's a year-long
maintenance thank you you'd rather just
get it out of the way in four quarters
yeah i don't
see i i love my family very much i feel
like i'm a family man i've got this best
dad ever signed up that i received two
fathers days ago and and i'm you know
i'm i'm on like a garrett-like streak of
ripken like streak his best dad ever uh
but on those saturdays recently those
michigan ohio state saturdays is when i
really throw myself into my love of
family where
where i have to around the first and
second quarter think you know what
football's not everything oh you know my
kids love me
i love my kids
i know that
what about our coach is it true he's
paying the university
cause they said bro you got to give back
all the money all you keep is that damn
jacket
oh these khakis ooh yeah is he going to
be there next year he i think so i mean
think about it david david allen grier
and the rich eisen show
they have won they they just haven't won
the game and it's just you really need
the nation needs to understand this if
michigan lost every single game
and only one one or two of those
particular games we spoke of yes ohio
state mooyoo he would be
golden
he'll be golden
reference to their to their agriculture
brilliant architecture agriculture yes
they're very good at agriculture yes i
know
um but anyway it was so close i was so
it took me to the height of euphoria
down to the depths
yes of i don't care
i don't care
i want to explain my outfit if you
please yes
i guess for the radio audience uh you
are wearing what looks like uh overalls
they are okay and is this sort of like a
seersucker um overall you know
it's a stripe okay that is not what they
would call a railroad stripe because
it's a little wider okay an engineer
type denim jacket yes uh open road hat i
i and you know my full beard i went to
pick my daughter up from school and i
it was like you know the scene from the
shirley temple heidi
when grandpa's lost in the snow
and she's in the house celebrating
christmas with the rich white folks he's
like honey
and she can't hear him and he's all lost
in the snowstorm that's how i felt
that's how i felt you know that's how
far away my world is to my daughter at
this point it's just but anyway this is
what i really wear i was gonna wear a
smart
outfit okay but i said it's rich he
doesn't want me to lie no i don't i
don't i want the real unfiltered david
anna grier on the rich eisen show you
know that's what i only can come to
expect and i would want
and so
i well i haven't i haven't like tried to
circle around and give you that movie
plug you know it's funny you mentioned
michigan okay um clifford by the way i
didn't do that you know i didn't do
anything no you could if you'd like no
it's good the movie's there
movie's definitely there it's hugely
popular it is um
listen i'm just happy to be in a flick
it was pre-pandemic
i say that because you know to do a
movie back then that was the old days
they just came picked you up you didn't
have to get in the morning get up in the
morning and do the survey the health
survey right you didn't have to get
tested none of that we just rolled in
the car you know face naked laughing
coughing and so you didn't you did this
all together so were you with john
cleese at some point at one point i was
i don't think he knew there was there's
a scene that we did it was a big finale
of the film right down at the river yes
and everybody i mean all the quote stars
were there
but over a maybe two acre
area landmass so yes i was there with
john
but not there with john got it and rosie
sure keenan all of them i not they were
over there they were over there yes why
were you
well i play the um i play the um
how do you say it
they put upon building super mm-hmm and
that's where they're hiding clifford so
there's a lot of what was that noise
hold on you hear something
why does it smell funny in here you know
stuff like that yes right okay
and so that's that
yes and i was true to my storyline so we
couldn't just like go and hang out okay
um and it was very regimented too
because that was a day where we had to
get this shot by a certain period of
time and it was all cordoned off in new
york okay so
and so when it comes to being a put upon
super you're a method actor is what
you're basically absolutely like you're
always in your role
i was pretty much i was and i love
shooting in new york she's in new york
again of course that's a big hotel it
was awesome
it was back when they would bring the
rooms like the room service would come
in right and they would just like touch
your food you know i mean back in the
day so who was your comedic influence
honestly um
you know comedy is generational
and i remember when i was really young i
saw richard pryor on the ed sullivan
show
now let me preface this by saying most
of my young life is i would watch the
mike douglas show every day after school
with my mom
and you know mike would have like
georgie jessel who was a guy i he was
just he might have been an alien of a
foreign body sure because he would come
on with this
uniform
he wasn't in the army but he said i'm
the toastmaster general and i was like
what i don't okay got it and he would
tell these jokes that they weren't funny
you had a weird voice too and no there
was no
semblance of comedy
um i didn't get it
and richard pryor was the first comic
uh who i saw
that made me laugh
and he was talking to me about me about
my world so that was did you ever cross
paths with her you ever meet him i never
i didn't want to i i come on really yeah
because i just because i remember one
time i did uh i did a play with lynette
mckee
and you know she did which way is up
with richard bryan she was oh my god
richard would love you david he either
love you or hate you and i was like
okay well then we don't need him dude if
it's a coin flip then yeah
i'm good i'm good but he was absolutely
my idol right
flip wilson
or so was huge huge and albums back then
of course
because i remember this is all old-timey
stuff but we had an annual paper drive
schultz elementary school in detroit
whoever brought up the most the biggest
pile they they measured it
um we would as an award we played we get
to play part of flip wilson's album in
class
cowboys and colored people it was a big
day at schultz elementary school mm-hmm
so yes flip wilson was was huge
very huge
and your favorite your favorite in
living color set
bit that you have i'm gonna say today
because i'm sure you asked that a lot
i might have even asked you that in the
previous segment um i'll tell you you
know
jamie foxx and i we did this
um sketch with james brown
and you know
wow i love james brown i grew up
idolizing him and when he died i was
like wow you know i was at home i was
going
man i wish i could and i caught myself i
go i did meet james brown we worked
together
so james brown came in and his hair was
permed and they said whatever you do his
wife is his wife at that time was his
hairdresser they said whatever you do do
not touch
mr brown's hair
this was a sketch about us
[ __ ] up his hair
[Music]
so
the whole sk and they said mr brown you
couldn't call him james j.j
b money it was mr brown
and do not touch his hair so i was
really scared
i was really scared and and did he not
know the
the construct of the bit or at all
someone told him at some point
you know maybe not read the script but
he's you know he's james brown yeah they
just would come in and whisper like okay
so when they uh go
you can get them you can do your dance
and walk out all right then
let's do it
and so we would do the thing and i would
pander mine touching his hair and i was
supposed to clip it and i and they gave
me the hair but every time i got close
to him he would like
jump and i'd be like mr mr brown please
excuse me mr brown so it was fraught
with tension it wasn't enjoyable but at
the end of the day i met james brown and
worked with him okay but you never did
in fact touch his hair i didn't touch
him i was i was instructed not to wow i
was instructed not to but
in hindsight it was historic
and i went back and i watched it and
it was funny because i know the back
story okay maybe not so much to people
that's a different kind of fun so then
what's what's the one that was most
enjoyable for you though i remember one
homie the clown
homie joins the circus
and
i was the glitter i was the good clown
trying to show damon how his clown
was a bad clown because he didn't have
the right clown attitude so i would come
in
and the whole time
it was really fun it was fun because i
kept making damon laugh because i was
i had the concentration of a robert de
niro for that particular sketch i was
goofy the clown
to my shoes mm-hmm so the whole day i
was like okey-dokey hold me
right you know i could tell you how to
really be funny oh that's a bad doobie
you want to be a good clown you got to
laugh like me
[Laughter]
you know and i was like
were you on break now homie
you know it was just really fun it was
fun and i did this walk you know
it was very funny it was but to me it
was fun do you still get residual checks
from that what's wrong with probably
akin to the check you just showed did
you taste
[Laughter]
really it you did see my resistance yes
i've gotten plenty of those but you know
the thing was technically when when
living color was on the air yes
fox claimed legally that they were not a
real network and they they said that at
the time because that affected how
residuals were paid because of the
number of what of
oh
they had and whatever
yeah so we got a lot of very sketchy
less than a dollar wow after a while i
mean it's been 800 years
but i i think most people like we do you
know when i was a little kid i was like
you know the dude who's on sky king he
must be a trillionaire
because i'm watching it and they're like
nope you know
um what donna reid sure he's a
trillionaire you know no no not so much
clifford the big red dog available now
in theaters and on paramount plus
spectrum originals new drama series joe
pickett check it out with uh with my
friend david alan greer premiering
december 6th exclusively on spectrum at
davidalangreer on instagram and
definitely on twitter where he's going
to be sending out that premature first
quarter tweet of go blue
when it's three nothing oh oh
i'm going immediately okay i can't wait
it's odd time baby
yes i'm going all in i don't care by the
way that's the new drop on this show
all next week when we're when we're
previewing michigan ohio state oh my god
i need that it's our time is it next
week it is next saturday a week from
this saturday all right let me ask you
before i go what do you think's gonna
happen um i'm i'm nervous sighted is
what my is what my children use the word
i'm nervous and excited about it give me
something to believe i think here's what
here here's here's the way to go is that
they is that they they time a possession
a defense that can be that can be beaten
ohio state's defense is their weaker
side of their
of their football team that michigan
timer possessions them limits their
possessions gets them frustrated hassan
haskins that has 170 yards rushing a
couple of touchdowns and and their two
their two ends um makes it a very
difficult day on offense for ohio state
so we got to catch them sleeping we got
to catch them on an off day and
michigan's got to control the football
and make plays on defense and get and
get ohio state off the field because you
know they're going to take us for
granted they'll take us for granted no
they will not take us for granted
never
never they will be whipped up into a
frenzy that's what they do can i tell
you one last story let's take a break
and then you couldn't come back and do
it okay all right amber stevens west she
played gerard carmichael's girlfriend on
the carmichael show
someone asked her to describe my
wardrobe and she said it's like david
works
in a factory but he's an actor
but that's how i dress you know i dress
like in
your blue collar yeah vintage old you're
from controls coveralls all the time
it's like i'm working on power you know
on auto plan so
last halloween my daughter who was 12
then she was dressed in her favorite
anime character and i took around the
corner we had like a little tea outside
you know masks and everything so we go
up to the woman who the hostess and she
goes oh first of all i love your
costumes especially yours sir are you a
farmer and my daughter of course she's
still laughing so he just fell out and i
said no this isn't a costume this is
the way i drew it
she was like oh okay i'm sorry
yes so that's my life no no you are who
you are when was the last time you
shaved
before the pandemic i answered
absolutely is this no maintenance at all
it is it is because
you know i did this um western joe
pickett um up in canada but i was
supposed to be a game warden so they
didn't give me this
sculpted beard they just like you look
fine
you know so i really have not shaved in
since
the second week in march yeah was it
2020 yeah yeah that's the last time so
you you look fine um
sounds like
that's that doesn't sound like you look
fine when they say it though well no i
mean because i want to look better
different okay than when i walked in the
trailer usually that's the goal all
right but that's not no this is uh you
know
it's an hour
drama they want realness and that's what
they they'd rub dirt on me and be like
you look fine okay
just the way that you you recounted it
it sounded like a passive aggressive
please oh everything i say everything i
see oh everything you say is passive
aggressive always always you know well
why don't you have a good day rich
yeah
no hey hey before i go
it's great seeing you
we have a segment here called higher
register that when people go higher
register they kind of don't believe like
hey maybe michigan might have a chance
against ohio state like that's that's
that by the way that could be our higher
register segment of next week we should
bring try this the next time you're like
with your wife and stuff honey do you
love me yeah i love you
it's exactly right the sex was pretty it
was that's good it's nice
that's pretty solid is the word that i
think is is uh is used but to the wrong
effect if you say something is solid to
me that's an insult that's the way i
take it back here on our radio
terrestrial radio network with david
alan greer you you you wanted to say a
story and you're like i just told you
the story so as my daughter tells me
there are utterances with no point okay
and you proved that point
i told the story and you doubled back
extra emphasis i did double i'm not with
that bull
so then i got out of the car and kevin
hart he was like where's the banana you
know
it wasn't that's a great story wow
that's only the punchline okay actually
there's no setup
i got it all right
um no that's it all right so you'd said
uh off camera as well that damon
breaking up damon wayans was your
favorite thing to do absolutely that was
one of the reasons i talked about that
sketch which
it took everything to keep him
focused because he was crying laughing
the whole day
because
what i was doing i was just being the
character and the more he laughed the
more i would just double down okay homie
are we are we on break now we had lunch
and it was just fun the whole day that's
what we did then it's time to do the
skit and it's no shot right no no no no
beautiful beautiful time we can't do it
now though don't ask
don't what do you mean do it well
everybody goes you know oh wow i wish
the living color were around now we
couldn't we wouldn't be allowed to do it
you would not based on what you're doing
no it's too
it was politically it was iffy back then
you know i mean i mean it really was so
in this environment no we couldn't do it
we couldn't do it but i just i think
people just seeing you all back together
as a cast would be something that i
think
many people would want to see it would
it's probably never going to happen just
because of
legal stuff but i you know i wanted to
do it before we got really old
um you know
um no but you know like that's one of
the reasons i i really hate
the rock and roll hall of fame because
you know
we you know especially in rock music
your gods these people we loved when we
were 15 16 in their prime of use and now
they have you know colostomy bags
that is what the the rolling stones tour
is called right oh my god
my god the colossally bag tour is that
what it's called yeah this is this
friend of mine
tweeted like a 15 year old i saw the
stones last night i'm like
what would you what would possess you to
tweet that
these are old men i mean i think it's
good
you saw him right mike didn't you no i
didn't i gave my tickets away he went to
egypt
no the eagles repeat what you just said
he gave i gave the kids
i gave away you know what i did seal
that i saw the stones once and uh and
the old pontiac silver dome wow back in
the late 80s that's when i saw it oh i
saw the stones at cobo hall and the 1872
it was the steel wheels tour and they
were so old then we were calling the
steel wheelchair tournament this is what
i'm saying they have been old
forever but i did see them in 72.
um
on acid
[Laughter]
my friends dumped me off on the front
lawn and my mom came out and she said uh
what's going on i was like this this
this stones are god you don't you don't
even know no wow this is amazing david
allen greer everybody
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here